a very large number of children just
aren't having the reading skills they
need to succeed in school the statistics
in the us are that so many children are
behind because of learning differences
because of poverty
the more we understand about how the
mind and brain learns the more we might
be able to use that knowledge to enhance
outcomes for many learners at all stages
of the lifespan
one area that i think would be fantastic
to really grow
is the use of technology in education
technology has revolutionized
practically every aspect of our lives
it has not moved education forward one
iota there is almost no evidence that
anything we do in technology has helped
kids read better do math better have
better social emotional well-being in
fact we're going the opposite way on
that rates of depression and anxiety are
up in adolescence
even before covered in the united states
we've had a clear mental health crisis
especially
amongst adolescents and young adults
which is so worrying and touching so
many families lives
some of the research directions we're
pursuing is early identification of
risks so you don't wait
until a child is in a full-blown
depression and then you can hopefully do
something on behalf of their child
we know technology can be amazingly
powerful it can be highly personalized
to individuals and so we think that
that's a huge both opportunity
and challenge
to say what can we do using the best
that we understand about modern
technology which has revolutionized
practically every sphere of our life
except
educational outcomes on behalf of
children
we want the kinds of skills in
technology and science and engineering
that are so amazing at mit
to be aimed at issues of educational
improvement
that kind of system between
scientific knowledge and implementation
has not occurred very well in education
we just haven't had much of a system to
say oh if we know something about how
learning can be improved whether it's
learning to read
stem learning social emotional
well-being on behalf of children how do
we know what program works for whom it
works and how to implement it
effectively
i think that mit can contribute to this
fear of opportunity and social equity
is to push not only the technology and
the science but also a scientific
approach to saying what really works and
for whom
you